[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles in ordnung
hallo
[Applaus]
helft mir
[Musik]
doch ich bin da keine sorge
ich helfe ihm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist vorne wie eine bell
und wir haben ja noch nicht montiert wir
müssen das hier anschließen damit der
bolzen da vorne raus fragt
bei erz heimat geht es um teamwork
das ist das wichtigste denn sehr oft
müssen wir in schwierigen situationen
zusammenarbeiten
wenn du in einer verschneiten
gletscherspalte best
engines
verschiebung aufstieg nun polytrauma
josef vertrauen spielt dabei eine
wichtige rolle es entsteht durch
gegenseitigen respekt wir müssen unser
können ständig unter beweis stellen
[Musik]
die zahl der
spannung
wer wo wie geworden bei einer
rettungsmission besteht das team aus
drei personen dem arzt
dem piloten und dem sanitäter
[Musik]
gut ist die aufgabenverteilung ist klar
definiert jeder weiß was er zu tun hat
da muss ich mal mit bevor und ja er holt
den patienten raus
wenn wir jemanden abseits der
kontrollierten ski-pisten retten müssen
holen wir uns einen berg
rettungsspezialisten
simon gehört zu unseren wichtigsten
bergrettern
[Musik]
auch bei unsicherem gelände brauchen wir
einen berg rettungsspezialisten
[Musik]
es bleibt erst mal da ist das nicht
das war okay
ich habe nicht voll aufgetankt
wir wollen das unnütze zurück
danke dass ich da gleich 50 kilo
leichter
starten
wir lassen den doktor hier komm ich hole
ihn wenn wir das opfer gefunden haben
die gletscherspalten sind brüche im eis
des gletschers
im winter sind sie durch den schnee fast
unsichtbar
riskieren jeder skifahrer oder wanderer
versuchte ihnen auszuweichen
das problem ist dass man sie nur schwer
erkennen kann
wenn eine gletscherspalte feld sitzt in
der falle
[Musik]
in eine gletscherspalte zu stürzen ohne
dass jemand es bemerkt
das stelle ich mir furchtbar
es könnte passieren dass du nie gefunden
[Musik]
er in eine gletscherspalte fällt bekommt
probleme mit der atmung der brustkorb
zusammengedrückt außerdem lässt die
wärme seines körpers das eis um dich
herum schmelzen so rutschte immer tiefer
in den spalt hinab
vielleicht wirst du auch unter
herabfallenden schnee begraben und erst
nach jahren gefunden
der weg zum verunglücken ist oft ein
wettlauf mit der zeit
wir müssen schneller sein als unser
größter feind der tod
meine erste begegnung mit dem tod war
als mein bruder fast ertrunken wäre
[Musik]
ich war fünf mein bruder 3
ich war für ihn verantwortlich
die forwind er fiel in den swimmingpool
der nachbarn und wäre dort beinahe
ertrunken
mein motto deine mutter holte ihn raus
und machte eine
herz-lungen-wiederbelebung
zum glück war sie erfolgreich
mein bruder lebt noch
[Musik]
ich glaube deshalb wollte ich flug
rettungssanitäter werden das war mein
erster kontakt mit einer
rettungsmaßnahme
[Musik]
da
wir müssen immer üben um vorbereitet zu
sein
die wahren kosten noch
immer wieder zu
verdienen
das leitprojekt als flug
rettungssanitäter muss man für spezial
rettungen ausgebildet sein die special
agent of risks
die
die koordinaten sind 6 26 450 0 0
87800 0
[Musik]
da oben sind sie sich stumm
das ist tief
hier kann nicht runter
machen
müller ich glaube wir stehen an einer
wunden stelle simon
es sieht nicht gut aus
das ist sehr tief
ich hab ich an holen soll das ist eine
wirklich tiefe spalte
wir heute ja wohl jan zum helfen
bei einer spalten bergung braucht man
mindestens drei bergführer die
ausrüstung fachgerecht zu bedienen
dies wird und vielleicht auch noch hugo
gute schön rechts bleiben
sportlich bringt nicht nur farbe mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
durch die freunde weg bringen damit sie
nicht im weg sind
ja es wurde das beste alle wegzufliegen
die vor ordentlich gebraucht werden
[Musik]
es ist ziemlich schwer einzuschätzen die
freunde eines opfers reagieren
womöglich haben sie einen freund
verloren oder ein familienmitglied
sie können sehr emotional werden wir
kennen aber für emotionen ist in einem
solchen moment kein platz jeden tag
seien die preise des moments
[Musik]
ich hatte links von der weg zu gehen
ich bringe die freunde zur basis und
kommen dann mit dem doktor zurück und
haben sogar noch 3
der umgang mit den freunden alles
verunglückten immer schwierig
sie machen sich sorgen um ihren freund
auch wegen der situation im allgemeinen
sie hoffen immer dass es gut ausgeht
aber es ist schwer ihre fragen zu
beantworten
mein vater mein großvater und mein
ururgroßvater waren bergführer
[Musik]
mein vater ist ständig aufs matterhorn
geklettert
ich bin damit aufgewachsen
es wird steiner
[Musik]
heutzutage kommen viele von außerhalb
nach zermatt
versuchen sich im klettern oder base
jumping
die aktivitäten werden immer extremer
und deshalb entstehen mehr unfälle
mit
dem schönheit der berge zieht die
menschen an aber berge sind auch
gefährlich
[Musik]
das ist nett zur erinnerung
ja glaub ich schon
in meinem leben gab es schon einige
tragödien
aus der kindheit
wenn ich daran denke
lasse ich den tod immer mehr
unglaublicher ich werde blumen bringen
andererseits schätze ich dadurch auch
die kleinen dinge des lebens
[Musik]
stehen das möchtest du ein butterbrot
simon
was soll denn drauf käse oder nutella
möchtest du marmelade so
lange soll ich auch welche essen
lecker
[Musik]
warum muss papa denn wegfahren ja und
ich hoffe papa kommt nicht zu spät zur
arbeit
wenn jemand hilfe braucht muss papa eben
zur arbeit
aber ich kenne wirklich besuchen kann
du willst mich bei der arbeit besuchen
dann sehe ich dich nachher simon
ich auch
so simon
ich nehme ein paar nüsse mit für den weg
axel hier ist robbie
vorgehabt die leute bringen die leute
und dann können wir die ausrüstung
wieder ein satz aus wissen
es nicht bleiben in bereitschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stock
in einer spalte bergung gehört das
dreibein zur standardausrüstung
ist rief es wird über der spalte
aufgestellt
mit hilfe der seilwinde können wir in
die spalte runtersteigen
die winden werden von motoren
angetrieben
dadurch können wir zwei leute
gleichzeitig hochziehen
man darf nie vergessen dass man auf
einem gletscher ist man kann sich nicht
so frei bewegen wie man möchte
es könnte sein dass die spalte plötzlich
einbricht
wie seit den sicherheit bleibt in diesem
bereich
[Musik]
folgende quer sturz in eine
gletscherspalte und meist gravierende
folgen dies ist bei einem so tiefen fall
kann man sich schwer verletzten gibt den
chip kommt nicht oft leidet man an
unterkühlung in vielen fällen ende das
mit dem tod
das sei es für mich und das für den
verunglückten
[Gelächter]
uns stehen sei in allen möglichen längen
und arten zur verfügung 70 80 meter
lange halbzeit richtig dünne es ist
schön so viele verschiedene seile zu
haben der sinn ist auf dem berg so wenig
gepäck wie möglich mitzuschleppen
ich arbeite als bergführer und wenn
rettungsspezialist bei air zermatt
[Musik]
rund um die uhr in bereitschaft
simon ist einer der besten bergsteiger
der welt
druck macht ihn überhaupt nichts aus
er ist einer der besten bergsteiger und
rettungsspezialisten die wir in zermatt
haben
[Musik]
simonis simon ist ein ausgezeichneter
bergretter um ihn muss ich mir nie
gedanken machen wenn etwas nicht nach
plan läuft
diese er ist ein spitzenathlet der sich
in null komma nichts auf neue
situationen einstellen
beim eisklettern ist das wesentlich dass
die ausrüstung richtig scharf ist
das schwierige ist dass der fels mit eis
bedeckt ist oft trifft man den fels
unter dem eis und dadurch wird die
spitze rund
[Musik]
es ist wichtig immer gute aus was dort
zu haben
[Musik]
man weiß nie wie nah man am limit ist
denken in den letzten zehn jahren bin
ich überall auf der welt aber
am meisten interessieren mich orte wo
noch niemand war
das ist unbekannte
in eine gletscherspalte hinein zu gehen
ist ein schritt ins unbekannte
[Musik]
das wird nicht leicht wenn 2 dranhängen
[Applaus]
hallo
alles in ordnung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tut es weh
[Musik]
ich musste noch zehn meter tiefer hier
ist wenig platz ich bringe den patienten
zum doktor auf
sagt er zehn minuten gesagt hätten
[Musik]
hallo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
holen sie mich raus keine sorge ich
helfe ihm
wie heißen sie
ich bin da ich helfen
den patienten ein stück kaufen
[Musik]
bleiben sie bei mir kommen sie
am meisten weh
so besser
wo tut's weh
bewegen sie sich nicht nur
schnell raus
wer dass wir sie beide gleichzeitig
holen simon beide gleichzeitig raus
ich etwas schneller aber zusammen
was ich kein problem
und dienstort ihren stopp mich auf
[Musik]
bleiben sie bei mir
die patienten ganz schnell hoch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doktor vor ort hand weg
wir sind zu klein
hörst du was über verletzungsmuster das
ist schwarz denn ich bin ich würde sagen
15 bis 30 meter
dass man mit dem patienten völlig
emotionslos arbeiten muss
es ist das beste rezept für den patient
und das beste
erfolgserlebnis für den patienten
axel ist der leitende rettungsarzt er
kann ziemlich aggressiv sein und das ist
manchmal nicht nur gut sondern sogar
notwendig
seine diagnosen sind unglaublich präzise
wenn axel auf der bildfläche auftaucht
ist das immer von vorteil
ganz schnell
[Musik]
apa
etwas absaugen das wird einen hoch kommt
können wir den fußball legen und dann
rein
[Musik]
doch noch zustimmt
du kannst dich mal bereit machen
vielleicht gibt er gleich bescheid
er bewegt bewegt jetzt noch ist gut sagt
zu machen
wie du kannst kommen du kommst uns so
ewig geben wir nennen die bauch heraus
paare unter der patient und dann beides
laden
ok
erst die paris
[Musik]
als der mann aus der gletscherspalte
hochkam und ich die augen sah wirkte er
wie tot hier lobte
dabei nicht mehr viel leben in flyff in
die partie
dann haben wir uns entschlossen
zwischenlandung hier auf der basis ins
amt zu machen um die notwendigen
maßnahmen durchzuführen
[Musik]
dort wo schnee da alles ist
01 fenster und dann wohl um ihn und
lasse laufen
so dann ist man ruhe bislang laden
die versorgung hier im hangar hat sich
dahingehend gestaltet dass wir infusion
gelegt haben schmerzmittelgabe
narkose eingeleitet die künstliche
beatmung durchgeführt haben und haben
versucht ihn mit chemischen wärme pigs
vor einer weiteren auskühlung zu
bewahren
[Musik]
aber hinter alles verblutet du musst
können glocken
00 auf helle 1
durch eine anmeldung notfall in unseren
spezialist meter sturz polytrauma
wenn jemand fragt wie geht es ihnen was
ist los
dann sagen wir einfach wir behandeln ihn
erstmal so dass er ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden kann
so wissen die leute bescheid
bei einer prognose besteht eine
fünfzigprozentige wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man falsch liegt
dann beim hochheben hat er wohl
offensichtlich so eine schlechte
perfektion hier oben gemacht sein
schädel hirn trauma dass er bewusstlos
leblos
denn soweit ich beurteilen konnte stabil
spontan bewegungen aller vier
extremitäten
hermann gelagert direkt am spalten rand
oft vakuummatratze
verletzungsmuster das überlasse ich euch
fragen
okay gut gemacht zufrieden
[Musik]
jeder einsatz gibt mir etwas das ich
nicht vergessen
der wille zum leben ist wirklich
erstaunlich
[Musik]
er wirkte das ist unglaublich welche
arbeit der arzt und die sanitäter
leisten
[Musik]
seit 25 jahren bin ich bei air zermatt
ich hatte mit verunglückten zu tun bei
denen ich dachte die schaffen es auf
keinen fall aber sie haben überlebt
er wie jeder der bei einem
rettungseinsatz dabei ist hat in
irgendeiner form mit emotionen zu
kämpfen
wir bleiben davon nicht unberührt
wer schon mal einen kritischen
rettungseinsatz miterlebt hat der weiß
wie unglaublich die zusammenarbeit ist
die zur rettung von leben führt
[Musik]
der patient hat großes glück gehabt
[Applaus]
also in die spalte viel hatte ein paar
eisstücke mitgerissen
dieser eisstöcke haben einen noch
tieferen sturz verhindert ich konnte ihn
mit dem eispickel befreien
jetzt bist du draußen und kannst dich
richtig strecken
[Musik]
es gibt bei uns keine vorher
festgelegten nachbesprechung
trotzdem sitzen wir in 95 prozent der
fälle hinterher zusammen und besprechen
das resultat com
[Musik]
wir arbeiten mit sehr erfahrenen leuten
die schon viele einsätze hinter sich
haben
[Musik]
aber man braucht in einem team auch
immer junges blut
geht es eben nicht was ein jogger hat
die unser teamwork ist wirklich gut
alles läuft wie am schnürchen
das wichtigste im team ist gegenseitiges
vertrauen es ist wie bei einem rennteam
der fahrer gewinnt die rennen nicht
allein sondern mit hilfe der crew die
hinter ihm steht
man muss jedem vertrauen können vom
anfang bis zum ende der rettungsaktion
[Musik]
zwischen denen die zusammenarbeiten
herrscht eine enge beziehung
sie verlassen sich aufeinander
und das funktioniert nur wenn sie sich
gegenseitig vertrauen
wir sind aufeinander angewiesen
anders geht es nicht
nasse
ich dachte es ist besser hin da
rauszuholen
ein rettungseinsatz ist erfolgreich wenn
er hoch professionell abläuft das heißt
man verursacht nicht noch mehr gefahr
störungen oder unfälle
wir sind bei der arbeit wie eine große
familie
[Musik]
sagst du auch danke danke bitte gern
ich habe vielleicht haben wir uns schon
gesehen aber ich kann mich nicht
erinnern denke ich mir das ist der
bergretter simon an dich kann ich mich
auch nicht mehr erinnern verständlich
der pilot
es geht mir besser
erinnerst du dich noch anders ich weiß
noch dass ich plötzlich den boden unter
den füßen verloren habe und als nächstes
mache ich in der klinik auf die
schlimmste verletzung war die
beckenfraktur
sie mussten das becken mit der
wirbelsäule verschrauben dazu
verletzungen an rücken
die mails und niere
[Musik]
es ist der wahnsinn und wirklich
bewundernswert wie ein team funktioniert
der vermieter sind die liebe kam
mehrmals der gedanke dass ich keine
chance gehabt hätte zu überleben denn
ihr nicht auf so hohem niveau
zusammengearbeitet hätten
es ist ein schöner ausgang
ich erwarte keinen dank für meine arbeit
aber
wenn jemand nach zermatt zurück kommt
und uns besucht hat man das angenehme
gefühl alles richtig gemacht zu haben
das ist eine große ehre für unser team
es war aber genauso wichtig dass du
überleben wolltest ohne deinen
kampfgeist und deinen überlebens willen
hätte die sache ganz anders enden können
manchmal kann ich einer familie nur
einen toten übergeben an anderen tagen
rette ich leben und bringe die menschen
sicher nach hause es hat geklappt
darüber sind wir vor wir sind alle
glücklich niemand muss mir sagen danke
du hast mein leben gerettet das ist mein
job und meine leidenschaft
[Musik]